et pour en parler de sommet les
agriculteurs nous sommes avec périco
légasse journaliste critique
gastronomique bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous périco légasse pour parler de ce
sujet mission parlementaire confiée donc
à un député par emmanuel macron vous
pensez qu'on va progresser avec ce type
de mission oui on sait très bien que les
missions parlementaires arrête tout de
suite suicides et que ceux qui étaient
dans une misère et dans la détresse
rosiers de s'arrêter non une fois de
plus de gouvernement se moque se moque
du monde et là on donne une une
sensation un peu de un peu de mépris
parce que la situation est vraiment
grave en masse au salon de l'agriculture
qui est le salon de l'industrie agricole
et la grande distribution ou la partie
paysanne n'est qu une devanture
folklorique pour amuser les visiteurs
puisque comme les espaces et un zoo et
on a tous les responsables de la
détresse agricole française les grandes
firmes multinationales et semencier le
syndicat majoritaire qui depuis 40 ans
cogère l'agriculture française et le
gouvernement et a envoyé la culture
française dans le mur qui devrait être
l'agriculteur français devrait être
l'homme le plus heureux du monde
aujourd'hui il ya une demande il ya un
contexte il ya un patrimoine agricole
prodigieux du savoir faire et surtout
une tradition on comprend pas comment on
en est arrivé là si ce n'est par un
système économique
la globalisation bien entendu l'europe
qui marchent pas la préférence
communautaire ne bénéficient pas osé
aller aux agriculteurs français
on importe des produits étrangers dans
une concurrence déloyale et je voyais
tout à l'heure les paysans espagnols les
agriculteurs espagnols sont en révolte
puisque eux mêmes sont maintenant
victime des produits maroc à l'afrique
du nord que la grande distribution
espagnol un port d'espagne donc chacun
sont tous bienvenue au club
et là c'est une un acte de cynisme les
différents gouvernements qui se
succèdent en france avec cette crise
agricole cette détresse agricole
c'est un cynisme et à mes prix sans
comparaison on a du mal justement à
comprendre pourquoi les présidents les
politiques ne défendent pas plus ce
qu'ils étaient
sorte de notre patrimoine pour quelles
raisons par lâcheté par idéologie par
manque de moyens par hommes n'ont tout
simplement ils n'ont pas la marge de
manager n'ont pas la marge de manoeuvre
parce qu'ils se sont coupés ils ont
renoncé à des prérogatives à des leviers
politiques nationaux et on a soumis la
rupture française ça remonte à longtemps
sans manteau gâtant 68 l'acte unique
européen
ce libre échange le marché ouvert fait
qu'on expose la rivière française à une
concurrence mondiale déloyale avec des
preuves des pays où l'on produit à
moindre coût et ce sont les conséquences
des fameux traités internationaux c'est
pour ça que les paysans français ne
veulent ni de settat ni du mercosur
parce que ça désespère à une concurrence
déloyale à laquelle ils peuvent pas
résister quand on produit dans les pays
d'amérique latine ou ailleurs en asie
des céréales ou des fruits ou en afrique
du nord à moindre coût que ces produits
arrivent sur le marché français où les
agriculteurs français sont un peu on
doive faire faire à des normes
environnementales des normes
nutritionnelles des normes économiques
tout à fait tout à fait légitime
eh bien ils peuvent pas résister et le
rock de des protégés de créer une
préférence communautaire
au lieu de faire une réglementation un
peu protectrice de la culture européenne
pas seulement française eh bien on ouvre
la culture française on la soumet on la
jette en pâture au marché international
et on laissera entraîner les produits
qui ruine les paysans c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui condamnées au
suicide on sait très bien comment ça va
finir
et tant qu'on ne remettra pas en cause
cette europe qui ne marche pas ce libre
échange sauvage et cette mondialisation
qui est ravi toute agriculture et bien
la france risquent un jour il n'ya plus
que 2 5% de paysans en france sur la
population
nous risquons un jour de voir
disparaître la totalité de notre
agriculture authentique soit remplacé
par les usines et des fabricants de
malbouffe
est-ce qu'il ya quand même des
agriculteurs en heureux en france on en
rencontre quand même de temps en temps
plus en plus de plus en plus parce qu'il
ya de la part du consommateur de la part
de la population une prise de conscience
sur une qualité améliorée de notre
culture il ya une demande pour des
produits sains respecter l'environnement
l'agriculture biologique est en train de
faire des progrès même si elle n'est pas
la solution totale idée définitive ya
d'autres traditions et puis il y avait
il ya des paysans des agriculteurs qui
prennent à bras le corps leur destin
grâce à cette prise de conscience du
consommateur
ces agriculteurs qui veulent sortir de
là il ya aujourd'hui une dynamique
certaine avec des progrès énormes ça
c'est indéniable il faut les encourager
et les pouvoirs publics le savent mais
la grande masse des consommateurs et la
grande masse des buteurs sont encore
d'un système économique qui est
accablant qui est catastrophique et qui
à mon avis va se va aboutir à des
concentrations il ya des zones
désertiques total il y aura t il en
france pour nous donner à manger
la france est même la première puissance
agricole en europe production estimée à
73 milliards d'euros en 2018 ce sont les
données de l'insee
l'allemagne n'est pas très loin derrière
et si wings tonnerre parce que
l'allemagne qui était la grande
puissance industrielle qu'à participer à
l'éradication l'industrie française
nous avions encore cet avantage d'avoir
une agriculture florissante et
performante
et puis les allemands ont remis en
service les anciens kolkhozes et des
sovkhozes l'allemagne de l'est
c'est à dire un productivisme outrancier
avec une production à échelle qui est
absolument démoniaque et aujourd'hui ses
usines à mal bouffe allemande inondé
pays européens et la france de produits
à bas coûts face auxquels les
agriculteurs français ne peuvent pas
lutter donc le la situation de
prédominance de la culture française est
en train de disparaître les allocations
européennes sont quand même allés le
plat plupart du temps aux plus riches
aux plus puissants et aux plus possédant
la rupture notamment les céréaliers
on commence aujourd'hui à répartir un
peu mieux et la réforme de la pac et
l'abandon des quotas laitiers on est
dans des mesures économiques et bien
fait que ce pays qui devait être
florissant et la culture françaises
devraient être à la france que
l'industrie à l'allemagne c'est à dire
sa ressource de richesse sa ressource de
puissance à ressources de prédominance
et bien cet alignement sur le sur le néo
libéralisme financier globalisés a ruiné
nos agriculteurs est en train
d'éradiquer la culture france est ce
qu'aujourd'hui un agriculteur français
doit envier
un agriculteur britannique non non parce
que
la situation est la même pour tous les
pays européens si c'était écrit avec les
brics alors que dans chaque pays il ya
des vallées dire des politiques je vous
parle évidemment en vue du bric citant
le futur agricole le britannique le drag
city évidemment rendre à apporter un
souffle nouveau aux agriculteurs anglais
mais les agriculteurs anglais avait déjà
eu conscience de tout ce qui est des
valeurs de la terre du patrimoine d'une
d'une forme de tradition agricole que
les français avaient perdu et est
évidemment le bric site va épargner va
éviter une concurrence déloyale aux
acteurs britanniques qui vont rentrer
dans un marché concurrentiel normal mais
en tout cas
boris johnson protège ses paysans et en
angleterre on n'a pas le nombre de
suicides
on peut tout dire de l'angleterre on n'a
pas le nombre de suicides qu'il y ait en
france donc là il ya peut-être un poids
à faire et peut-être faut regarder la
situation en face savoir qui dit la
vérité et qui ment et qui envoie les qui
envoie les paysans à la corde
c'est pas rien c'est pas ceux qu'on
croit qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
quand vous voyez ces images de politique
déambuler dans les salons de
l'agriculture souvent la veille des
présidentielles en l'occurrence des
municipales 1 de tous bords depuis des
années c'est bien bien déclamé en même
temps pendant non parce que c'est
scandaleux c'est un rituel traditionnel
tous les chefs d'état
fond cette visite j'allais dire dans un
dans un programme quasi cas quasi
folklorique
on vient promettre des choses on vient
rencontrer ça se passe souvent mal un
françois hollande avait été très mal
accueillie on vient faire des promesses
à la classe paysanne et aux agriculteurs
qu'on ne tiendra pas on leur fait croire
que tout va pour le mieux et qu'on va
prendre les problèmes à bras le corps et
en fait à la fin du salon une fois que
c'est terminé
les agriculteurs rentrer dans leurs
campagnes vivent leur détresse vivent
leur misère ceux qui se sont mis
j'allais dire du fric plein les poches
qui sont les puissants les industriels
ressortent content parce que c'est une
kermesse c'est la kermesse de la fille
de la financiarisation d'agriculture et
les vrais paysans restent avec leurs
problèmes et leur détresse c'est le
salon de l'hypocrisie de la fourberie
elle a été finalement avec tous les
gouvernements on avait d un jacques
chirac beaucoup plus populaires
peut-être que que d'autres a longtemps
ça vraiment été la foire on l'analyse et
la sphère agricole avec des la vitrine
de la culture française dans sa
diversité florissante la province et les
campagnes montée vers la capitale où les
parisiens venaient voir et le monde
entier allait voir et puis un jour ça a
basculé de salon des campagnes
françaises
c'est devenu le salon de la finance
agricole 7 est tombée aux mains des
financiers aux mains des banquiers aux
mains des industriels aux mains des
trusts aux mains des lobbys aujourd'hui
ce sont les lobbys il faut écouter la
démission de nicolas hulot en août 2010
8 expliquant les le bio 1000 mais la
mamie sur ceux sur la production
agricole de ce pays pour comprendre
pourquoi aujourd'hui le salon de
l'agriculture c'est le salon des
fossoyeurs et pas le salon des
agriculteurs qui veulent vivre
aujourd'hui qu'elle est finalement
quelle serait la priorité les trois
mesures à prendre
notre consoeur karine lemarchand salue
d'ailleurs a lancé le grand débat sur
l'agriculture pour une durée de trois
mois
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire justement
sortir tout de suite la culture
française d'une concurrence déloyale à
laquelle elle ne peut pas résister la
protégée relancer une production
intérieure respectueuse de
l'environnement un certain prix une
éducation scolaire sur la façon de
consommer des grandes campagnes pour
expliquer aux consommateurs français
qu'il vaut mieux réduire les quantités
ce qui engendre une économie qui permet
de financer une qualité meilleure et de
repenser notre consommation en tout cas
protéger d'urgence les secteurs
agricoles les plus exposées à la
concurrence déloyale internationale
un protectionnisme intelligent mais pas
forcément français c'est en europe
gunther pas à la france et dire aux
agriculteurs qui font un très beau
métier faciliter leur installation
foncière parce que là aussi ça coûte
très cher et faire en sorte que la
grande distribution le plus le scandale
de plume le majeur de ce quinquennat
c'est la loi des états généraux de
l'alimentation la loi et galim issues
des états généraux qui est un fiasco
total ou le président république avait
promis que désormais ce sont les
agriculteurs qui fixerait leurs prix et
que ces tarifs ne leur serait pas imposé
ni par les industriels et par les grands
distributeurs et jamais la concurrence
n'a été aussi sauvage jamais la grande
distribution d'imposer autant ses prix à
la production et jamais on n'a eu autant
de suicides donc alloué galim c'est une
c'est une forfaiture c'est un mensonge
est aujourd'hui l'urgence est de faire
en sorte que la grande distribution ne
tremble pas les industriels qui eux
mêmes sont tenus de l'étrangler les
instructeurs
c'était une mesure simple et précise
faut juste avoir un peu de courage
politique pour la mettre en place merci
beaucoup périco légasse d'avoir été avec
nos journalistes critiques
gastronomiques merci à vous